agenda number one apologies for absence
yeah the only one i have is anna dark
who ran me yesterday morning her son is
then we go with not anna
but we agreed probably wise if she
stayed away
so over to you you've got more about the
same today yes thank you chair we've got
councilman
and councillor brenton
thank you
any substitutions
no i wasn't aware of any chair
right proper job
now we moved item two minutes of the cnr
meeting
of the sixth of december pages three to
eight i'll move from the bottom of the
pages move them through
the comments on them please
[Music]
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
are you
no comments
or happy with those minutes can we
please show please
[Music]
oh i need a proposal sorry i'm trying to
move councilman christie's proposal
counselor hudson's second there those in
favor please share
one two three four five six
those against
those abstaining
two
[Music]
that's right
apologies for
[Music]
the action list
section this is starting to get a bit
longer
um
any comments there too
[Music]
have anything been dealt with
satisfaction
or
[Music]
nothing to
[Music]
yes but we have 106's coming up in a
moment
uh sure chair i think just a update on
uh certainly
the action 197
uh that letter was sent
last week
um and i i will check whether richard
said i've seen the schedule
on
minute
or action number 86 but i don't know if
that's been said okay
no no okay i'll get rich to send that to
you
could you currently awkward
[Music]
it's our h is richard hayes not me yeah
chancellor
[Music]
um the public health and housing manager
should check and get back to him
[Music]
the public health and health manager
right well rather than just getting back
to of laws can this committee be
informed of what your response is please
okay
okay
are we happy with the action next
we move on
public contributions i've had no
notification of any
no nor is anybody else
so we moved to item five the forward
plan on page 11.
there anyone wish to add or delete
or comment
nope
so then we move on to
item
seven
now items six
decorations of interest it's there you
all know the score by now i'm not going
into details
item seven
as far as i know we have no
part two items nothing that needs to go
to part two so that's fairly
straightforward i think
i to make urgent matters
plus there may be plenty somewhere i
don't know of them i've got nothing to
bring forward
[Music]
so we move to item 9 the section 106
process
off it goes
thank you chair can you remember to see
me clearly yeah yeah good thank you
so i've been asked to provide an
overview of the 106 process and funding
allocation
it's pages 12 to 17 um in your committee
agenda
um i'm not intending to
reread my report my trust members have
read that
but the report basically
goes through the process of
sectionalized cities starting with the
planning background
moving on to how section 106 agreements
are agreed through planning process at
pre-op and planning application stage
um the monitoring of section 106
agreement uh following essential ones
has been signed
and then the plan stayed uses the
distribution of funds and application
process for unallocated funds
um some elements that i've just
highlighted to members
is that in terms of planning background
you'll notice in my report i've listed
what's called the sale regs
and there's three particular items there
which are quite important for sexuality
to process
and that's in relation to what actually
can be um considered as section 106 and
what obligations can be achieved
and there's three rules first one is
that they must be necessary to make the
development acceptable in planning terms
second being that they're directly
related to the development
and the third they're fairly and
reasonably related in scale and kind of
development
in terms of the uh 716 agreements and
negotiations
um
section 106s are negotiated in
accordance with our local plan our
planning policy and national guidance
board members are involved and consulted
as part of the planning application
process
um
and the trigger points and the actual
amounts obviously designed to go to that
stage
before the session 106 is actually
signed
once section 106 is signed there'll be
trigger points for when the obligations
are received um and that could be
throughout the developments depending on
what the obligation actually is and
those trigger points are monitored by
your officers at charleston council
by a variety of means including
consideration of birth control records
site visits and council tax records as
well
finally in relation to the allocation
as you know from my report there is a
process for the allocation of funds
which can be directed to town and parish
councils um as well as other groups
and there is an application process
which
is on our website application
applications4 and the guidance for that
and in certain instances those
applications may come before yourselves
as cnr as well as we had last october i
believe
i'm happy to take any questions on the
detail i'm sure members have got a few
questions for me um so chair if you
happen to take questions
right that's right um uh we'll
cancel or not start on page 17 where
you've got the capital government how
many of those items are over five years
old
so the five year date i'd have to go
back to the actual detail to go through
each one council got five year dates
from when we received those funds but i
can certainly go through those and find
out and return to members which ones are
over five years
um just on that five year basis
it's normally written for session one
six whether it's five years some of them
are ten years from the older ones um it
can they can be ranged from two through
to ten um five is sort of being average
that tends to be on set of one or six
degrees okay
cancel revolves
yes
very often it seems to be decided or a
chance of dashing and grabbing money
[Music]
it just seems
the system just seems broad to me
one of the first places you go
is the war members no definements 106
being negotiated and they must have an
input
[Music]
[Music]
and we don't seem to be involved
[Music]
the stage at which all members are
exerted are once the conversation
responses are in um because in terms of
hesitations and requests for obligations
the officer may not be aware of that
until that first consultation period
from devon county council for example in
the nhs
so at that point an email would accept
the war members outlining the
obligations that have been sought
and also
the viability process as well
as members will be
well aware that a lot of our
applications are sort of a viability
process
which national policy allows
and as part of that viability
assessments are assessed independently
constitutional council will instruct
instructor independent assessor
and it will be on responsible that
liability assessment uh that with
conservative members if it does go down
that route
to ensure that the members have most
up-to-date information on what's
actually being stored with the
obligations
i do think there is
an issue in that section 106 is are
considered under the outline application
uh or full application and i am aware
that in some instances the outlying
planning commission could be granted
many years ago um five years ago
potentially
and when members see a reserve matters
application come in we can't reconsider
that 706 because that's already been
silenced by the outline application and
of course members may not be involved
now like adaptation due to the time
period
and indeed due to our process haven't
changed over the last two or three years
where they are now involved
so yeah i do appreciate that
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
years as a counselor i've not yet been
consulted on a 106.
[Music]
but there has been development in my
awards
and one of them appears on this list
i knew nothing about it
it would depend on the date of that time
application when that was dealt with um
we've certainly been certain for the
last two two or three years
or we
[Music]
[Music]
so i don't know what the variance is
there and um
also
i believe that quite a few of the
projects it was allocated to have
actually been completed so just
wondering why they've been closed
uh down have to have a look at the
actual detail of that application
i'm sure we can discuss that afterwards
um
there are various reasons why the
figures may be slightly different um
bcis
indexing for example um
and the actual cost of different
obligations may change during that
period of time um
clearly we can only utilize the money
for actually what it costs about um
if something's allocated to a certain
project it has to be that project um if
there's any underspender overspend we
can't seek let's move that around
but i can certainly go through that
application with you perhaps
james
where it does
[Music]
other one is we don't know
why they need that money so i'm not
being consulted at all um even though
i'm raising
this question about the planning at
times so
i'm sorry we're just not being
[Music]
well that must be one of the few that
have been consulted in three of my
villages the planning officers that deal
with my area have been very very good
and supportive and they always come back
to me and they go to the chair of the
parish council and they say if you don't
want any green infrastructure can you
come up with some other plan so i've
been very
very impressed by the offices
in my world
is it your presence on the planet's
committee
i couldn't possibly respond to that
counseling
council
and you know
the same system that she's saying has
happened to her
no problem at all and but i sit on class
committee as well so generally myself
it shouldn't make any difference no
no i mean i'm quite happy
with it no problem
[Music]
[Music]
thank you very much
um just coming back to the fact of the
passage of time
and outline planning commission may have
agreed a section 106
way way back
does this not bring into question the
length of time of deliverability of
these schemes
in the fact that
it came to my attention when i got quite
excited about development in
westwood home
where it appeared
from the section 106 that had been
agreed back in the year dot that we were
going to get a
30 or 35
um
affordable housing contribution on a
scheme i think it might have been even
higher than that
but the actual time limit on the
planning application just run out and
expired and a new one was subsequently
put in
um
which
dispensed with all that
106
agreement
so i'm concerned that if we have these
very historic
uh permissions
how long can they legally run
before
is it the length of time of the
application panel is an online
application balance
and i'm quite sure my planning committee
followers know that but i don't
and my second question is on page 17
crossland gardens seems to have about
150 000 as well as their money that's
already been allocated
um
what is that
for
so that's sort of two questions because
that seems like is that a
typo
uh it seems an awful lot of money
thank you
um in relation to the timeline for
outline commissions um
on every planning commission whether
that buying a full
there's a condition that's required for
lead time um and that's how long that
permissions alive for
that can vary depending on the
commission and it tends to be with
outlines three years potential for
submitting reserve matters up to five
years
um of course with a full application if
somebody makes a material commencement
to that planning permission then that
competition remains exact um
i'm sure
yeah a material commencement will keep
that alive
um in relation to
uh ruslan gardens um i actually also
questioned this because i wonder whether
his typo with our accountants and it's
not they're three different uh
confusions towards affordable housing
um so that was linked to an affordable
housing obligation um
yes
there are three separate obligations um
what i can do is i can forward you the
text with section 106 agreement from the
meeting so they're not all affordable
yes they are they're all but they're
separate obligations during the sex 106
agreement which is why i separate
separate lives
right well perhaps we can have
the mist cleared from my eyes
lately it's about the wording in the
actual session once there's a legal
agreement so we can really share that's
fine
all right
thank you um
yeah i put the motion to the full
council quite a few years ago that ward
members had to be
um approached about sexual assault and
it's still odd that there seems to be
some sort of brain damage and it was
voted on by full council it is part of
our
um
[Music]
i won't say constitution but it is part
of our agreement
um viability studies you mentioned um
i've now got those presented to the
planning committee but
they're pointless really the one thing
they don't tell you is how much they pay
for the land which makes the whole thing
ridiculous anyway going back to section
106's um
can i ask how much has been replaying to
developers
do we know has any of the developers
ever claimed the money back
i would have to do some research on that
consequence
i don't really do too much i just think
how common is that because
[Music]
i know from one instance that
the developers have gone bankrupt and
they weren't they had claimed it back or
something but somebody ever repayed
money i'm not aware i am aware of a
developer um asking us that question
last year and there wasn't actually any
money to pay back that
[Music]
um section two in your report the second
paragraph it's already inserted by
counter james um about this uh
heads of terms and so on pre-application
discussions
i i was fascinated to see that because i
keep raising this issue about we'd never
get the 30 before
and
i i've asked can we actually
get the landowner to pay for a viability
study
before any land they own is included in
our district plan
if it doesn't beat 30 doesn't get
included and uh
i was told the last planning meeting
when i raised this that
the landowner wouldn't know what was
required yet this paragraph seems to say
well actually
i'll come back to that actually i think
that's a
very interesting point
um can i also ask um
one thing
you say the town council the parishes
can then use the money as it were if
it's not used specifically
um
do you actually tell the town councils
or parishes because i had to make my own
inquiries
as to what money there might be nobody
had told me that there was still money
lying there doing nothing
so our town councils and parish councils
are they told
that
there is money available
um
i'm sure they are directly it's on our
website
and we keep an upstate list of um
allocated funds on the website
where we'll actually tell directly i'm
not convinced um but that's part of the
process but of course we can we can look
at that and we can certainly make that
the case could you because the money i
access was something for public art or
something bizarre that i don't think
anyone would have thought of
um but you know there is money there and
town councils can use in the parish
council that'd be great
um can i a specific question because
about one section 106 group does that
allow because this came up with planning
and
it's about the section 106 to do with
winsford the developer is refusing to
sign it
and i have asked
what then happens
because that's going to be the new
school for victor but also i ask ian
ronan if they don't sign section 106 do
we then
have to find land for another 750 houses
which is what that planning application
was for
and he said yes we will
is that is that right this section 106
is
it is the actual kind of tipping point
you don't get planning mission to sign
it so what is the current state of that
yeah so we've got to i don't really want
to get into the details of particular
applications but that one there i'm
obviously aware of
um section 106 hasn't been signed
and as uh you'll be aware of counselors
this is one that went to plans county
some time ago um a number of years ago
due to that the obligations have changed
planning policy has changed with our
adopted plan in 2018 um
so it's one that would have to come back
to committee in any case
um
negotiations are ongoing at the moment
with developer about section 106 um and
where we go forward with that
application um if the section 106
remains unsigned
and
essentially we wouldn't be issuing the
planning commission so the u.s with a
750 house gap in our allocations
for housing strategy for local plan
so in reality
we could have allocated that site moving
forward and we could look elsewhere as
part of the
review
and that's
that would be the final um
that would be the end game really if
that section one six wasn't signed um we
wouldn't be able to ground planning
commission without that um but as i say
it is being negotiated at the moment
because that's it was originally
negotiated on the basis of the previous
local plan and not the existing doctor
plan and it's likely that it will come
back to plans committee at some time
this year
so the section 106 could actually be
awesome
section one says could be that hasn't
been signed
up or down
there well that would have to come back
from transcommunity anyway so that's
going to be aware of that and really
interesting
[Music]
right
i have
[Music]
a mr back who is on the
uh standards and scrutiny committee as
an independent member
i am told he can speak at this meeting
thank you
i was just going to introduce myself
because people wanted to develop i was
sitting here with my hand up
right so you've got no questions
actually
but i have a question oh yes please say
go on she said i'm not able to speak yes
you can speak thank you very much man
it's about the section 106 models and
when the monies are agreed between
the local authority and the developer
um obviously the board member the
councillor is informed about the
the money's involved are the local
community consulted about how that money
can be spent
or is it for the world member to make
that decision
so the section one of six obligations
the money can only be spent on certain
elements that's within the section 106
um going back to the seal regs which is
what i quoted earlier on those three
particular rules that they have to
follow
and it's very precise that the money has
to be spent on those particular
obligations within the office's
dedicated report or committee report it
will be listed
those particular elements and the
amounts that has to go to those elements
so on that basis uh yes it is that um
very direct is very focused um it's not
a case that we've got pop money spent
everywhere or on anything um has to be
focused what's in the section 106.
thank you
[Music]
applications come in and on the last one
they didn't want any further green
infrastructure
they didn't think you know it was
necessary within the village so the
planning officer came to me and emailed
the
parish council and they discussed what
they would like and they said they would
like um to resurface the car park of a
village hall
so they reported that back to the planet
officer and she said she exactly that
she would have to see if that was
covered by the rules of the section 106.
so i thought that was quite a good
example that the parishes do get
involved through the parish councils
principal james
well i was just going to pick up on um
number four
by the third paragraph where it does say
that before they started the tunnel
parish council i have to say in 40 years
on a parish council
20 years on the district council
that's news to me
where i'm being left is with the sort of
question mark as to
the erratic nature of the notification
of members that's what it seems to be
some of us get nothing in others
being well served
and i think we ask you sean please to
look at this carefully because
i don't know what's going on
hence the question
um the section 106 money is
it's a reward
but if it's not spent within that wall
can it be spent in other wars because
my mind goes back to western home i mean
at the first big tournament
where i think eight hundred thousand
pounds
it was a sex 106 affordable home they
didn't want affordable
flats because they said the people who
would take them would be able to afford
to service charges therefore they gave
torah 800 000 pounds to provide
affordable housing and we were told it
couldn't be provided in westwood hope if
it wasn't the land or something and it
was spent somewhere else i thought so
can it be can this money be to
actually turn into other wars
yeah so the the second element was still
works so that has to be directly related
to the development
now ordinarily that would be actually
related to that development and the
surrounding environment of that
development
what we can and we have successfully
argued in the past for example um is
regard to strategic elements a good
example is a swimming pool
so if you have a development in westwood
hill for example
there's a very we can make a very good
argument that people who are going to
live in that new development would use a
swimming pool um elsewhere outside the
water
strategic sort of center so we could
seek monies outside the ward for
that affordable housing
if there is a potential that actually
it needed to provide for affordable
housing but it could provide it on the
actual site and there was no house
nowhere elsewhere within that ward that
could provide affordable housing you
could look at a cascade a bit wider for
that
um so yes we can but we have to be very
careful how we deal with that and how we
look at that
sean just to come back on that a
specific point i think you can see it's
related to horizon
we were told at the time
several times
[Music]
some years ago
there was money allocated to the uh
reciting the
pitch
and i understand that that money
suddenly
[Music]
[Music]
think there might be some confusion here
because i i think that relates to
uh
sure from probably nursing downsides but
i think there's some debate around
contributions from the site uh just over
there um bid five is that one and
winsford as well
there were some uh contributions
negotiated that were then found not to
be self-compliant so we couldn't take
them so that money was never actually
held
well they started work on the new
cricket field in appleworld
replacing the one in westwood yeah
and then
suddenly it was gone i have to say this
was just prior to my time
one of the reasons
such
i don't think they actually started work
there was a piece of piece of
feasibility work done on a relocation
site for the club in anticipation of
those funds becoming available and they
never became available so that worked
for supported
[Music]
the money for the racket center chair
was uh negotiated as part of the
development
and you approved a council alone to them
in advance of
section 106
thank you for enlightening me
right any more on this item
which doesn't call for a decision in any
form
uh i suppose technically we know that
uh councillor
sorry can we make a recommendation that
uh further investigations are made into
the equality of information sharing the
parish councils
and that
any disparity in
the approaches to board members uh
come back to this committee and be
remedied
since the laws yes that's exactly what
he decided the last guy and it doesn't
it's obviously false regard but we're
not being intentionally cut out of
notification it's just that some seem to
qualify for comfortable members
thank you
yeah um
somehow sean you've got to look at this
one
do we want it to come back at the next
meeting as to what is happening
with james you're affected by it yeah
yeah would
like to i think it just falls through
the system sometimes rather than us
anything malicious or negligent um so my
life um perhaps a short report back to
say hell in the future it is actually
going to ensure that all members
get the notifications they should okay
there's one last point is there a
possibility of
biddeford
it is probably easier in the rural areas
where
you've got one council of another
village in biddeford we have section
106s and yet benefit is a single
community
it might be helpful if all the
counselors in a bit of a knew what
section 106 money was because
um we've had one just recently actually
where
um the skateboard park
was going to get 75 000 pounds from the
development of easter water um
the eastern water councils weren't too
happy with that the money was coming to
western waters so but
couldn't all the councils in bills have
been told that is because
we do act that you know we are a single
community
and it might be helpful for all councils
to know there is section 106 money
because
uh we're all aware of what he's doing
but if it may not be in your ward it's a
bit odd to
sort of
keep it in the side of what war
could actually benefit the whole
community
i've got no problems with it most rural
awards are too much rewards now actually
um
yep okay sean yeah yeah happy with that
share and then i can certainly come back
we'll pull back to committee
right we move on now to item 10 i
believe
miscellaneous fees and charges perfect
okay so every year
uh we seek approval from members to
increase our hand fees and charges
approval refusing charges for the year
ahead
just to give some context to fees and
charges and enthusiasts generate the
council approximately 6.4 million pounds
worth of income
and uh various in their nature so a lot
of fees and charges are actually
statutory nature they're set by central
review so unsurprisingly planning fees
are set by central government because
anybody is putting in a planning
application they've got no choice but to
come to us if the development is within
storage
and some fees and charges are
discretionary in nature the council
isn't right to make charges on that
there's other components that play
sometimes the fees and charges don't
believe the cost sometimes the fees and
charges
can't show a profit over a three year
period for particular partners such as
land charges
um just to give some context to the fees
and charges that have been presented to
you in this report
this is that time of it's actually high
inflation i think the report mentions
that cpi in october is 4.2 percent
and i think rpi was six percent in
october so october november is about the
time we start
formalize these um feature charges with
managers
so i don't intend to go through 20
15 16 pages of fees and charges there
and have to take any questions but the
recommendation is that members approve
the fees and charges just laid out
just to know that the fees and charges
previously we'd give you all the fees
and charges in the appendix just to cut
down on paper as much as anything we're
only going to hear the fees and charges
we're actually seeking to change so you
won't have in the planning fees
um etc which are step by government or
any licensing fees which is statutory in
nature
any
questions right counselor laws off here
i'm not sure whether it's in here
because i haven't been right through
this list
but pavement licenses uh
when kobe's driving we don't seek to
help
businesses by allowing pavement
the use of pavements
or cavities and things like that
that has been results
[Music]
facility
um
equally
it's added something to westwood as a
result it was quite continental that you
had something outside the vision shop
tables etc
[Music]
do we have a set payment license because
it really should be implemented when
trading comes to an end
because if we don't implement it then
it's going to be taken it's free
[Music]
so yes the answer is yes we do have a
paper license we administer that to the
county so it used to be a county
function came there was a directive last
year where we picked up responsibility
for administering it i don't know what
the fear is on top off the top of my
head but i guess it's not here it's not
supposed to change
um
so big issue in the license
the understanding when it transferred
over was the set criteria associated
with it that the county applied and we
simply
if you like make sure that those
criteria have met there was something of
a policy decision taken because of code
issued at the guidance of government
which is around us being as flexible as
possible with the application of those
criteria i think in the past in the last
12 months we've probably issued licenses
for paper trading that we wouldn't issue
in normal trading times so we're going
to need to look at that policy line
at the top of page 27 right there's a
payment license charge at the top of
page 27. does that mean
they've actually applied yet because
they didn't realize
there will be some in here we don't
actually have those just in case
somebody wants to
build a greyhound track or a racecourse
track with insiders that would be
charged by digital
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
arrived at that
[Music]
why is a football pitch cheaper than
rugby pitch
i don't know the answer to that
well it must be a reason
are the rugby club being overcharged or
are the football clubs being
undercharged
[Music]
as i read it football pictures of 47 and
repeat
outside of 53 or 49-66
[Music]
[Music]
yeah um
i know the
crematorium sets its own themes and that
covers the cost quite well but i see
we've got the burial fees down here
um and it says
i assume it covers its cost quite well
because they are quite expensive
um pre-booking of grave plots of
northern times no longer available due
to a limited amount of remaining spaces
if this is a cash stream for torrid
which i assume it is um
i'm aware that
torrington
and now that's totally wrong
and
[Music]
which is now on the tabularly site we
were told it was unsuitable for a
graveyard
i think there was a previous decision
taken and i can't tell you when it was
or what committee took it that uh the
absence of spaces would mean that people
from over would be very benefited i
understand from certain people that
that's a highly unacceptable
circumstance so like i said sunday with
you
chancellor
i need to speak to my deputy mayor we
have had discussions with um the town
clerk
with regard to this as a an issue
and um we are
it's not urgent urgent but it is
something that
going forward we are going to have to
debate as a council
and i know that some sort of research is
being done about the availability
potential availability of land just to
identify a reasonable area for travel
because we don't have anywhere
specific within
our parish so it might have to be
bordering on the edge of that parish
but there have been some um
very loose early discussions on this
but i wouldn't want it noted that we're
you know scaring the
land but we are discussing it and we are
aware of the issues and as you so
rightly say
biddiford was mentioned as an
alternative
and you can imagine the response was um
not overwhelmingly supportive
so
thank you
that's electricity just to follow up on
that um
i was thought this is getting quite
depressing actually because i take
historic tours around northern i go
through the graveyard because it's a
really interesting place and every time
i go it seems to be less and more space
there and it seems to be very little
space left actually
my only question is is the statutory
function of torridge very minded in the
rural areas the paris church does it or
we get out and do it you know
whatever
why
torridge doesn't run graveyards in rural
areas
yeah i guess it's a
question for our property team rather
than our finance manager and something
we can add to the action list to take
away
um
and also it doesn't represent the cash
flow i'm afraid
back in 1841 we were actually one of the
very first municipal centuries in
britain and we've done it ever since i'm
not sure
why you think we don't have to do it now
i mean if we didn't do it who would do
it
private radio
privatization burials
anything else with charges and whatever
council hudson i'd like to recommend the
content of this report that
members here
accept the increase and
noted in the fees and charges report
[Music]
please
thank you
now we move on to the next item
which is going to be chris taking it
and that's urban renewals
good morning members um
this evening your piece should hopefully
be seen as a great opportunity not only
to leverage external funding
to create future regeneration potentials
benefit but also as an opportunity to
really
collectively map out future wider
opportunities for the town centre
it was always seen that isaac yard
would be the catalyst
for that kind of wider program of
regeneration and growth
yet uncertainty over that scheme as a
result of not securing leveling up
funding
ensures that it's essential that we now
look at that wider piece as well
although this initial report is very
much a devon county
piece of work
and a significant amount of funding for
this work will come from devon county
and sean and i are very clear that this
needs to be very much driven by tdc um
working with the town council
and also making sure that we use this as
an opportunity to not just have the same
voices involved but also to extend that
pool of
skills and experiences and interests
especially as a result of the volume of
new arrivals into the area in the last
couple of years
as such
the goal for this isn't it is not just
looking forward towards the future
leveling up
application and exploring opportunities
that might be around that but also
looking to ensure that we can attract
future developer and private sector
interests
and
investment into town which is something
that hasn't been the case for a long
period of time
on that note are there any questions
queries or thoughts please
when we talk of biddeford
is that just the town of biddeford does
it include northern west window what
area does it include
uh the data that was used uh for the
report is focused on the biddeford town
center
okay
um i noticed torrington is in here
in the devon document but not in the one
that's put forward to us at the moment
what's happened
so
the
proposal from devon was to look at
investing in a small number of towns
rather than to spend the funding across
a large number and effectively water it
down to the point where nothing could
actually be achieved from that funding
funding that is part of the
recovery perspectives
the
data sets that we used indicated that
benefit should be
the return where the investment is
focused on an insurance
um i think what they've recognized in
all of this work was that they're issues
in all of the likely talents across
the most acute ones
and they've certainly pulled out benefit
as the area of most need in our district
and what we're trying to do in this
report is sort of balance that out a
little bit by refocusing a post that was
saying chris's team to work with torrent
and holdsworthy and all them
on the initiatives that they've got
coming forward to help their own centers
okay cancer change sure
i think what it does highlight is when
we talk about leveling up funding
um
when we're in class one which is the
most
the
[Music]
um
yeah thank you um
when i heard the words levelling up
uh i wondered about you know how come
basketball got
because what would be here over the
weekend it does seem
you know there's political manipulation
going on now i'd be very interested to
hear about that but could i ask um
you're asking us for fifteen thousand
pounds and you've said it mainly
but what do we get for our fifteen
thousand pounds
where is it going
so
i think within the report there's a
section which
in effect if you look on page 44
what we're looking to deliver
through the
initial piece of work is to make sure
that
the
master planning
and
business case development work is
undertaken
to make sure that in effect
we're then able to create
almost a series of smaller business
cases which are then ready for
investment but also to attract external
investment
so not just a case of being
able to move into various funding bids
but also to start attracting wider
interests
i'm sorry but
that sounds great but where's the money
going
what's it going to be spent on
so i know for example that and then have
already procured
master planning and
concerning to least on a lot of the
work
with us sorry for us couldn't speak up
sorry of course
uh so i know that devon have already
procured uh the master planning
consultants to
lead on a lot of the work underneath
that piece of work there's then a range
of um economists and
uh i think there's some low level uh
design work so there's a huge number of
pieces of work that would be
[Music]
to work with the regeneration boards to
invest in a series of
almost quick win activities as well so
our 15 000 effectively will be
leveraging the 45 000 external i think
from devon county
so basically it's going to consultants
and large amounts yeah
that's great uh i don't think that room
higher and be a paid for for the crew
whilst they're discussing it i'm not
sure
cancer chris didn't carry on well now i
only say that because
we all know consultants are ready you
know they're ragged or ball
um i'm really sad to hear that there's
going to be consultants again
i'm sorry about this but i have to say i
was reading the old newspapers the other
day in 2002
torres were asked how much they spent on
consultants for brunswick wharf
110 000
back in 2002 which is more than we sold
it for and i hope we don't get into the
same situation where all the money
goes into another plan which sits on the
shelf
because there's been a lot of those um
this is that you think and i'm asking
you that you're our economic generation
this will produce concrete results
i really hope so council christian
really helps
as uh you will know and uh coming back
to council james's point as well
there has been a huge amount of work
undertaken um especially during those
last two years as a pandemic and i would
say there's been a lot of good work and
good proposals that have come
forward from that hence my um
you're empathizing with your frustration
around
investment that has gone elsewhere that
we don't necessarily fully agree with
[Music]
but
with every passing day
the
needs
increase
as sort of cancer james again alluded to
there are so many things that need time
and attention
now what those need is capacity and
expertise to be able to look at them
um
i single-handedly at the moment wouldn't
be able to
kind of
work on all of these strands whilst
giving great torrenting the
attention it needs whilst looking at
opportunities within northern town
council whilst then started to open up
projects and holes worthy
and also i wouldn't necessarily have the
requisite skills to be able to deliver
on all the different functions that
hopefully we're going to be able to
bring forward from this so i would agree
it's
we'd love to see money spent on the
ground
but we also have to work within the
parameters of the money that is
available to us
can i suggest one thing then
you say i don't know which council to
say about um going out to the wider
community than just counsellors and
asking their views and it may sound
silly you probably won't agree but a bit
of a banter
online
website
uh lots of silly jokes and other stuff
but is there any chance to put the
questionnaire on there because that has
i think when i last time i looked it was
something like 25 000 people
online bigger than the population of
benefit um
i mean it would be interesting to hear
that i know a lot of them
will be you know why doesn't the council
reduce the business rates you know stuff
like that which we can't do but
it might be an interesting exercise just
to see what people
out there i believe when we and started
the community engaged with the
we did put kind of links uh to the
survey uh into the likes of good of
advancement um such and also having
other more business critical streams
such as businesses from pitta bay um
part of the issue we also will need to
face
when going out for community engagement
in birth
is the fact that
we've
almost been told quite a few times over
the last two years in advance of
the future high sheet funds and the huge
amount of work that was done for that
and then
checking in again for the leveling up
front
people have almost said this is what we
want this is what what this is what we
want
and due to that funding not having this
was coming
it's been a certain sense of
so we need to make sure that we're
checking in and listening and seeing if
there's any changes on that
but also trying to find ways to get the
community to believe and to get behind
things without feeling well it's just
another funny bit it will never come to
benefit
i think you're exactly you put your
finger on it there
um we've had so many of these over the
years but uh if i can quote you all
words i i hope
it all works out well i i
i will keep fighting and working hard
and keep open because we need to
there's been several of these um
bids over the last few years to
regenerate the central benefit and it's
been a
real tragedy that none of them have
actually come to fruition you know to
date
but um i would like to move this
recommendation that we that we accept
this um
this proposal because it's a small price
a day if there is the slightest you know
possibility of a major scheme you know
actually happening and ready for
something you know it's a small price to
pay for
what could potentially happen in the
future we you know we've come this far
we've just
to support this recommendation um
hopefully something comes on
one second
james
i was going to propose
i support it because the fact is
you know it's much funding um and
denver county you're fairly keen on
doing this and again
it's always sit back and say well i'm
gonna put money to it and that's why
and so i'm happy with that and also you
know chris without meetings with chris
he's one laggy and what we've talked
about is that with seven countries
that we may find a little
and as i said earlier
[Music]
because we haven't got the resources we
haven't got the staff
chris has gotten chopped up into several
bits and we want to be attending
chancellor
yeah i've just got one query on page 48
the full will it put it down it says
support the creation of the townsend
project officer is that just amazing
into torrid or is that covering the
whole endeavor
a town center project
just the torres so that would be new one
new boat
so we had a role of the economic
development project officer um
which
that person moved across to a different
team
we then
advertised twice
to replace that role
and actually has zero applications
because the term economic development
project officer for a lot of people
actually doesn't really mean very much
[Music]
whereas
most people have strong opinions
on the town centers
now
what that does mean is that kind of
that role will at times operate outside
of town centers as well
so it's not sort of purely saying that
person won't have anything to do with
rural communities because actually a lot
of the opportunities for example through
the creation of uh
future workspaces there's crossover
learning there that has to be
ensured but it will also free up some of
my time and some of the time that's
going by for example the community
engagement project
to make sure that we're then working
with some of those rural communities as
well thank you
right i've got no one else wishing to
speak as i understand it
the proposal was that we accept all the
recommendations on number five
so i'll put that to the vote those in
favor please share
that is you now must thank you
thank you chris thank you
now move on item 12
um it's just a very quick update for
members i thought you'd be interested to
see how we're getting on with uh setting
up activator registers to run our
leisure services
so the the points to highlight uh we're
currently developing in an improving
relationship with 1610 and working
through the dilapidations and building
improvement schedules so that's really
something that's positive i've seen some
really improvements there
we're looking at what equipment we need
matt our head of leisure operations is
uh actively designing up the new gym
equipment in the asian 1610 about what
they've got there that we might want to
keep and organizing those things
uh 1610 have given notice of all of
their utility contracts and we're
obviously trying to get new ones
arranged because we need power and water
and the like broadband so that's
underway
active storage is now set up as a
company so we own active torridge
um and
it's registered with companies house
logo has been approved and it's there
for you to see
the sort of superhero a as it's been
described and your company colors are a
teal and maroon so that's good
uh the company has agreed it's strategic
intent
and those points are listed there for
you
um
probably the most important thing that's
going on there's discussions around
staffing uh 1610 obviously have a uh
an existing workforce that will come
over to active torridge as part of the
transfer
we haven't actually been able to engage
uh personally with the staff here but uh
those discussions are happening soon
and and i think one of the other things
picking up on the last point there
is that we need to get a marketing
communications plan in place as soon as
possible and start picking up some
members we uh we've set a business plan
it's it's not particularly bright on the
finance side at the moment we need to
get as much business as possible we need
to tell people about what we're doing
with the service so it's just a very
brief update for you all just to let you
know that things are going well and
we're still on target for the first
april
taking questions
right i'll take comments and questions
thanks for pushing
thank you i think it's important that we
advertise and promote this at an early
you know as early as you possibly can
because i i found actually quite a lot
of people that use particularly the
northern blue that they ask me what's
happening with them or we should have a
pool what's going to happen the gym
membership etc there's a lot of
uncertainty out there
for the actual people that use it so i
think you know whether it's
adverts in the journal the gazette
online etc we need to push the message
i think i think you're absolutely right
cancer bushby and certainly one of the
reasons for this report was to put into
the public domain what's coming and we
need to keep that message coming on um
yes the communications of this is going
to be absolutely integral in anybody can
speak to work that's fantastic um we
also like to say haven't had a chance to
speak to the staff directly and and we'd
like to tell them we'd like to reassure
them that things are really positive
moving forward
counselors
they look
tired
and a bit
we're arranging for cleaning in march
thank you
yes can i ask you
how does some active devil compare
um with active toys set up a new company
isn't there certainly overlapping going
on
yeah does this i would say
uh possibilities for collaboration uh
active devon is a program that's set up
to get people more active active
torridge is a company that we've
established to run our leisure services
um and i think that as active torridge
develops it will integrate a lot with
active development
thank you
so this is a report from noting
no one's wishing to comment on it at the
moment
i think this is very much now one for
hari roper
can i have a formal note that we've
noted it please
[Music]
proposed by rose council a lot seconded
by councillor christie all in favour
that we've noted it inanimate
thank you
and i believe that brings me to the end
of the meeting
11 12.
not the shortest one